the popular Shah shirag Shrine and
Shiraz was packed with people when an
isil gunman opened fire Witnesses say
the attack during evening prayers was
time to cause maximum damage
[Music]
we were preparing for prayers and then
we heard the gunshot we tried to escape
from the other side and then I realized
I was bleeding I could not see who was
shooting and it was from outside but we
were inside the shrine It Started from
the street and then they came towards
the shrine and they shot whoever they
saw Iran some of the victims were
brought to this hospital they spoke of
their shock at the attack
I went to Charlotte with my children I
heard sounds of gunfire after he prayed
we went to a room next to the shrine
this gunman came and fired a barrage of
shots bullet hit my arm and leg it hit
my wife's back but thank God my child
was not hit he's seven years old
popular with
Shiraz last witnessed a similar attack
14 years ago Wednesday's shooting comes
at a time when security is on high alert
in Iran following weeks of protests
across the country
the aim was to attack worshipers it came
at the sunset time when people go for
prayers and he has killed a lot of
people so the country is in shock
Iran doesn't see this type of terrorist
attacks normally
Iranian president Ibrahimovic condemned
the shooting which he said was an
attempt to divide the country through
violence and fear he said there would be
what he called a severe response to the
attack Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera